[Music]
surprised at night
welcome to the wire
leave your entries in the sir really
close and I should maybe we should
synchronize episode of why work of
everybody to live like YouTube favorite
show and yours too I hope of course hmm
remember to subscribe if you haven't
already does you just hate when people
ask you to subscribe when literally it's
just been fifteen seconds of the video
how shameless can you possibly be anyway
have I told you about my chair it's a
great price free shipping if you are in
Canada
[Music]
Canadians wat phan how do you do anyway
last week I asked you to get me some
memes which I asked you every single
week this channel it's literally just
means by now up vote to remind Felix of
the peak of his career this this is a
classic attempt of you guys to try and
make fun of me all right
like that was a cringy performance why
the hell did you sing live when you
literally have Sarah singing talent huh
you know a lot of people look at YouTube
as a as a great way to make your dreams
come true go onstage have an audience
have people that appreciate that what
you do go out and have fan meetups and
meet and greet when literally I just
want to sit here and look at memes
alright that's all I want I want none of
that things that disappear when you need
them the most your keys your wallet your
phone Friday when you guys are such
whiny little crybabies fridays with
pewdiepie was the show i did back in the
day and everyone is like literally I
could call this show Fridays repeater
pie and you'd all be like oh well it's
the same thing it's the same thing it
was a show based on community activity
and I brought it back and it's been back
this whole time but you're too dumb to
even realize it because you're all just
a bunch of whiny crybabies someone's mad
normal people they go they come home
they go to sleep
it's actually really comfortable in
there the mother art gay Navy and like
half of these are not even pewdiepie
related it's great keep it up
the life speedify the better alright
because the nice complaining and whining
about me black ops 2 black ops 3 black
ops for backup 30 legit five years ago
fine
I made this fake video called black ops
for when it's literally just clickbait I
think I played spyro or something we got
free running and I was like alright so
how do I make that the logo looks looks
stupid and realistic at the same time I
just add another another bar on the logo
and they did it absolute mad land I
predict everything because I'm a genius
that's right can we bring back that good
old meme huh who would win their most
trusted name in news
CNN don't make me laugh some guy with a
broken chair
what do you mean broken chick but can
you dodge this yeah I came alright my
latest video for 24 you're welcome
I bet you couldn't make a sentence
without a you thought you just did
something here didn't you well sorry to
burst your bubble but numerous senses
could be constructed without employing
the first letter of the English lexicon
pub G PewDiePie pub G for kids PewDiePie
for kids that's right
I make really edgy and really wacky
jokes that Jack films fans wouldn't even
understand the level of my comedy so I
made this Android app called Beauty fire
radio
I gotta check that out oh my god it's
right there
oh my god it's live what the hell
[Music]
doctor you have cancer you're gonna die
man no you doctored all this time we had
the cure for Casey and it was memes that
makes no sense
the paradox when you had kale for lunch
and the green screen does its job yeah I
really appreciate that I have really
great editors that really fixes these
small weird things instead of putting
more attention to them if you're having
a bath if you're having a bad day
remember that a man from Canada known as
bitch'll Angelo uses a GPS tracker of
his bike rights to draw pictures Wow I
[Music]
still don't understand my god so
annoying oh I can't it you edit it in me
in my own video criticizing myself oh
how clever so annoying it's just
annoying people like this people like
this [ __ ] this is really confusing
because I'm wearing the same shirt
there's too many there's too many
PewDiePie's in one screen here what's I
sometimes wonder what happened to Falcon
never oh look at this and another
classic week's parody pie after
retirement legit like I'm already in my
retirement I don't think you guys
understand all I do all day is sitting
this extremely comfortable chair have I
told you about
anything ahead and I look at means okay
I am already living there retirement
life guys not know bullying please okay
you should be striking down on bullying
videos so please don't bully Miss Piggy
she I don't want her to and you mean
becomes popular PewDiePie
twelve-year-old crybabies please okay I
have the freshest memes all the time
I elevate the memes I'm the catalyst of
memes alright I make the means become
means that's how influential I am okay
so don't come crying with your oh he
killed the mean who this is as bad as
behind the mean okay
accept me for the Messiah that I am
instead of hating
everybody we are now entering the second
page of means we step it up a bit
these are supposed to be the the
middle-class mean let's see how they do
peer deep I can surely do this but can
he do this why did they get out this
joke has been made a million times legit
I have fans walking up to me and putting
out their hand awkwardly being hey hi
what are you gonna do now huh what are
you like come on I know how to shake a
hand all right I know how it's done
please stop wasting my time and
spreading your germs to me all right I
don't want to touch you why do you think
I meant that the brofist because little
as possible human contact misery man
breaks into multiple woman's homes to
tell them he respects them in
celebration of International Women's Day
Wow can we get a round of applause to
Jason Augustine everybody a true member
of the respecting women society and team
chucks reppin that Sookie Murch come on
next thing you're gonna say it we didn't
we ripped off that as well people still
talk about this I said if I get a
hundred thousand subscribers I will
strip on camera hashtag strip for us
boots and I still haven't done it if I
get ten million subscribers I will do
nudes how about that oh that's sick
ed get the dog and finish the Hugh oh
and girls thank you how many children
have mental health disorders that's
right you can joke about a mental health
disorder that's fine man Edgar got
bigger Wow Dan by the merch please by
the merch where will he come from this
time all the interest possible hey
what's up guys laying on his $3.99 chair
be sauced I'll jump scare probably
answering the door
oh oh oh looks like I was ahead of you
little no Brad the Edit King oh look at
that Brad you get to get recognized as
well
too bad no one cares about size skip ad'
3:19 and i said skip ad no no no no no
no guys
whoa
this is strangely hypnotizing oh because
I'm Joe okay because there's the same
thing
Wow disgusted creative and unique
editing trick to make video funnier to
achieve fake how about that Brad Wow
okay
I've seen this one it's honestly so cool
that anime thing in the background where
is it from I need to know normally I
feel really weird about Peter Pine
tattoos but I honestly think it doesn't
even look bad like it's a proper tattoo
and of course who wouldn't want a pretty
pie tear meme on your skin forever
chair how much am i worth to you Peter
pay three oh my god you show me and I
hate you chair commit suicide Peter
Piper's chair screen
[Music]
they would like if you cried